E
SHOW BECAUSE HE GOES ON THE
CLOCK.
MEANWHILE, THIS:  WE START IN
WASHINGTON, D.C. WHERE IT'S
BECOMING INCREASINGLY CLEAR THAT
THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY DOESN'T
GIVE A DAMN ABOUT YOU.
YOU GOT AMERICANS BECOMING
INCREASINGLY CONCERNED ABOUT
EDUCATION.
THEIR CHILDREN, INFLATION.
CHAOS AT THE BORDER AND GAS
PRICES.
WHAT IS HAPPENING IN WASHINGTON?
DEMOCRATS AREN'T EVEN LISTENING
OR EVEN PRETENDING TO.
IT DOESN'T LOOK LIKE THEIR
AGENDA MATCHES UP, TO I DON'T
KNOW, ANYBODY'S AGENDA EXCEPT
THEIRS?
MASSACHUSETTS REP AYANNA
PRESSLEY'S OFFICE PHONE HAS BEEN
SENT TO VOICE MAIL FOR THE LAST
18 MONTHS.
AND ONE OF THE THINGS SHE SAYS
AS SHE LISTENS TO HER
CONSTITUENTS?
I HOPE HER CONSTITUENTS HAVEN'T
NEEDED ANYTHING FOR THE LAST 18
MONTHS LIKE, I DON'T KNOW,
ANSWERS ON WHY THE GROCERIES ARE
SO EXPENSIVE.
GAS IS DOUBLE, AND A WHOLE LOT
MORE LIKE THE SUPPLY CHAIN AND
CHRISTMAS.
INSTEAD PRESLEY' SIGHTS SET ON
SOMETHING ENTIRELY DIFFERENT.
>> CARE IS INFRASTRUCTURE.
HOUSE SOMETHING INFRASTRUCTURE.
CLIMATE JUSTICE IS
INFRASTRUCTURE.
PAID LEAVE IS INFRASTRUCTURE.
DISABILITY JUSTICE IS
INFRASTRUCTURE.
LET'S PASS THE BUILD BACK BETTER
ACT.
>> Brian: ALL RIGHT.
YOU GOT THE GIST.
SHE DOESN'T CARE WHAT THE PEOPLE
WHO ACTUALLY ELECTED HER HAVE TO
SAY OR EVEN F. THEY EVEN HAVE A
ROAD TO DRIVE TO.
INSTEAD FOLLOWING THE LEAD OF
AOC AND OTHER SQUAD MEMBERS,
PROGRESSIVES AS THEY TRY TO PUSH
THROUGH THIS MASSIVE SPENDING
BILL READS MORE LIKE A
PROGRESSIVE WISH LIST WHICH THEY
CURRENTLY CAN'T EVEN APPROVE
BECAUSE THERE IS NOT ENOUGH OF
THEIR WISHES GRANTED ON THAT
LIST.
WHICH IS OVER 1600 PAGES.
IT SEEMS LIKE THE GOVERNMENT IS
DOING EVERYTHING POSSIBLE TO
MAKE YOU, DEPENDENT ON THEM.
JUST LOOK AT HOW THE WHITE HOUSE
ENVISIONS YOUR LIFE.
THEY HAVE ACTUALLY RELEASED THIS
COMIC CALLED THE LIFE OF LINDA.
FOCUSES ON A SINGLE MOM AND A
SON MAKING $40,000 A YEAR AND
SHOWS THE GOVERNMENT CONTROL
THEM FROM THE CRADLE TO GRAVE.
LET'S SHOW A FEW OF THEM AND
LOOK AT TOGETHER.
IT'S REALLY EXCITING.
LET'S START HERE.
IT'S TIME BECAUSE YOU HAVE A
CHILD TAX CREDIT TO GO SHOPPING.
NOW YOU CAN AFFORD IT WITH THAT
$300 PER MONTH.
AFTER SHOPPING, I WANT YOU TO
DROP YOUR SON, WHO IS SUPPOSED
TO BE 3 BUT LOOKS LIKE HE IS 13
AT PRESCHOOL FOR SOME HIGH
QUALITY FREE PRE-K CARE.
AND THEN LET'S TAKE A LOOK AT
FREE COMMUNITY COLLEGE.
GUESS WHAT IT YIELDS?
YOU LEARN A TRADE TO GET THAT
UNION GOVERNMENT JOB WHERE YOU
BUILD WINDMILLS.
THAT IS INDEED THE GOAL.
I DON'T KNOW, IS THAT THE
ASPIRATION OF EVERY YOUNG WOMAN
TO BE A SINGLE PARENT
DESPERATELY TRYING TO GRAB HOLD
OF A GOVERNMENT JOB?
THIS IS THE SAME GOVERNMENT THAT
HAS NO PROBLEM TAKING YOUR HARD
EARNED DOLLARS AND PLEDGING IT
TO PEOPLE BEYOND OUR BORDERS IT
BRINGS ME TO THE NEXT STORY.
CASE IN POINT, "WALL STREET
JOURNAL" TODAY.
THE BIG STORY, I DIDN'T EVEN
THINK IT WAS TRUE.
THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION IN
TALKS RIGHT NOW TO OFFER ILLEGAL
IMMIGRANT FAMILIES SEPARATED
DURING THE TRUMP ADMINISTRATION
$450,000, MAYBE MORE IN PERSONAL
COMPENSATION TO RESOLVE LAWSUITS
FILED ON BEHALF OF PARENTS AND
CHILDREN WHO THE GOVERNMENT
SUBJECTED THEM TO LASTING
PSYCHOLOGICAL TRAUMA BY
SEPARATING THEM AT THE BORDER,
SOMETHING THAT WAS REVERSED BY
THE PRESIDENT THROUGH AN
EXECUTIVE ORDER THE PRESIDENT AT
THE TIME, PRESIDENT TRUMP.
YOU HEARD THAT RIGHT.
450,000 A PERSON.
AND MIGRANTS ARE GETTING THE
NEWS THAT YOU CAN CASH IN ON
TRAVELING WITH CHILDREN.
THAT'S GOING TO BE A GO SIGN FOR
EVERYBODY ELSE.
AS THE A.P. REPORTS THE NEW
CARAVAN COMING FROM MEXICO IS
FULL OF CHILDREN.
SO FORGET MAKING WINDMILLS.
APPARENTLY ALL YOU HAVE TO DO IN
AMERICA TO GET RICH IS CROSS THE
BORDER ALONE AND THEN SEND FOR
YOUR PARENTS LATER.
THINK OF THAT MESSAGE IT SENDS
TO OTHERS IN OTHER COUNTRIES.
AS TAX DOLLARS OF HARDWORKING
AMERICANS LIKE YOU ARE GOING TO
BE HANDED OVER TO LEGIT
CRIMINALS WHO FLAT OUT BROKE OUR
LAW.
SENATOR TOM COTTON PUT IT VERY
WELL IN A QUOTE ON A TWEET
SAYING THIS:  PAY A BURGLAR WHO
BROKE INTO YOUR HOME FOR THE
PSYCHOLOGICAL TRAUMA THEY
ENDURED WHILE DOING THE CRIME.
REMEMBER, THEY CAME TO OUR
BORDER ILLEGALLY.
SO, HOW DOES THIS END UP?
WHO IS ADVISING THE PRESIDENT?
TEXAS DEMOCRAT CONGRESSMAN HENRY
CUELLAR BROKE IT DOWN ON THE
RADIO WITH ME TODAY.
REMEMBER, DEMOCRATIC CONGRESSMAN
FROM TEXAS.
LISTEN.
>> HE HAS SURROUNDED HIMSELF ON
THE IMMIGRATION ISSUE WITH
PEOPLE THAT HAVE BACKGROUND
IN -- I WILL CALL THEM
IMMIGRATION ACTIVISTS.
THE ADMINISTRATION GETS ADVICE
FROM CAREER PEOPLE AND FROM THE
POLITICAL APPOINTEES.
THE CAREER PEOPLE IN HOMELAND
AND OTHER PLACES THEY GET IT.
I TALK TO THEM.
THEY GET IT.
BUT, YOU KNOW, YOU GOT POLITICAL
PEOPLE THAT MAKE THOSE TYPE OF
DECISIONS AND IT'S UNFORTUNATE
THAT THEY ARE NOT LISTENING TO
THE CAREER PEOPLE, THE MEN AND
WOMEN IN GREEN AND BLUE AND
OTHER FOLKS THAT HAVE BEEN DOING
THIS FOR SO MANY YEARS.
>> Brian: SO YOU UNDERSTAND THAT
IF YOU ACTUALLY WANTED TO SOLVE
THE PROBLEM AND YOU DON'T WANT
TO DEAL WITH REPUBLICANS, YOU
HAVE A DEMOCRAT WHO LIVES ON THE
BORDER ON A BORDER STATE
REPRESENTING DEMOCRATIC
CONSTITUENTS WHO PUT HIM IN
OFFICE EVERY YEAR.
HE HAS THE ANSWER TO THE BORDER.
HE GOES TO OTHER COUNTRIES.
AND HE ACTUALLY STAYS IN HIS
COUNTRY.
AND THEN TRIES TO GET THROUGH TO
A DEMOCRATIC PRESIDENT AND HE
DOESN'T EVEN TAKE HIS CALL.
IT